this is Karolina Karolina you live here  in Mexico City I do I'm gonna do a show  then I try some jokes out on you girl el  vuelo de los angeles acidity Mexico solo  tour de tres horas emedia pero el taxi  del aeropuerto a me hotel toilet those  Diaz megusta Kentucky stays and would  idioma take casino say ba a si si no a  recess for the menos tengo una exclusive  [Music]  no stereo  [Laughter]  pero el taxi del aeropuerto a me hotel  Parador those Diaz  [Laughter]  [Applause]  pero el taxi de aeropuerto amiyo tell  tardo those deals and then that  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  I had no idea what they were singing  about as I was dancing how could you do  that to me they're not gonna let me back  in the United States now come live with  you guys whether they understand it  I could work do I play a little guitar  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  you  you